- [Narrator] If five is
divided into pieces that are
each one half of a whole,
how many pieces are there?
And this would be the
equivalent of saying,
"What is five divided by 1/2?"
And they help us out with this visual.
So pause this video and see if
you can figure out what that is.
How many pieces would you
get if you divide five
into pieces that are
each one half of a whole?
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So here on this number line
we go from zero to five,
and then notice they've
divided into pieces
that are each a half of a whole.
This is one piece right over here.
So how many of those halves,
so this right over here is one half,
how many of those halves
does it take to make five?
Well, two halves make a whole,
and we have five wholes.
So it's going to be five times two, or 10.
And we see that right over here.
One half, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10 halves make five wholes.
So this is going to be equal to 10.
So five divided into pieces
of one half, or five wholes
divided into pieces of one half
would be equal to 10 pieces.
Let's do another example.
So we have a similar question here.
Here we're asked,
"If three wholes are divided into pieces
that are each 1/6 of a whole,
how many pieces are there?"
Once again, pause this
video and think about it.
Well, they really help
us out with this visual
because we have three wholes.
This is one whole, two
whole, and then three wholes,
and then we have divided them into pieces
that are each 1/6 of a whole.
This is a sixth right
over here, this is a sixth
right over here, so each
of these are sixths.
And so, if we look at this,
we have six sixths in a whole,
and so in three wholes we're
gonna have six, 12, 18 pieces.
And you could literally
just count these up.
But it makes sense.
If you take three wholes and
you divide it into sixths,
so this is a sixth right over here,
each of these wholes are
going to be six sixths,
so three wholes are going to be
three times six sixths, or 18 sixths.
There you go.